So thank you for taking the time
to come visit Google and, uh,
we're all just going
to kick off with that.
You were returning from the first film,
Bad moms.
I'm not fitting and Christmas
is approaching in this film.
So where do we find
each of your characters?
Okay,
wow.
Oh, I'll start. Well,
Kiki has much repaired her
relationship with Ken. I'll say that.
Uh, she stood up for herself, which a lot
of times when you stand up for yourself,
you sort of set new boundaries and new
dynamics in your life, which she's done.
Kent helps out a lot at home.
Uh,
he is no longer a never heard
if you know what I mean?
So she has a thriving sex life and uh,
she's still friends with both these girls.
But I think as life ebbs and flows,
you go through waves where,
you know,
the moms felt like they took
a part of their life back,
but Christmas and the holidays are
approaching and they feel like it's just
slipping away.
All that control.
That's where, Yup. I love it.
So good. Amy, where's Amy? So,
hmm. She isn't a relationship.
Spoiler alert with, um, with the J.
Yeah, Jesse, that's his name. And uh,
that's right. Jay Hernandez. Slash Jesse.
Um, and, and is it a very happy place in
her life? She, it has filed for divorce.
Everything's great. And uh,
you know, her, her mother,
her mother comes into town and throws
her in for a loop of spiraling out of
control and feeling like she's never good
enough and that nothing she ever does
is good enough and a feeling the pressure
to be as perfect as her mother while
having these wonderful women, it
try to help themselves and her, uh,
be strong and powerful and go
against the system of Christmas.
Oh,
well, uh, I, uh, uh, Carla,
Carla and a Mimosa.
Um, uh, Carla is trying, you know,
I think if from the last movie,
I think his is,
is trying on a modicum of thank you.
Um, some responsibility in her life.
She has a job now, I think
she took, she works at,
she's an aesthetician and all
that that entails at a spa.
And so I think, you know,
she's trying to have some,
a little bit of responsibility. It's
just her and her boy. And then, yeah,
mom walks in who I haven't
seen in years and years.
I don't think Christmas in their
family was ever, uh, you know,
sell a really stolen,
really care. Um, yeah.
So I think that's where you see her.
I was trying to,
I think she's trying to have a little
bit of responsibility and trying to enjoy
these last couple of years with her
boy before he goes away to school or
wherever or, you know, who is she
kidding? He's never leaving her home.
Well, this film was directed
by John Lucas and Scott Moore,
the duo best known for the hangover films.
How much were you able to influence
the script this time around?
Uh,
I would say yeah, a lot. Um, he
was a really nice collaboration.
Kind of hate the sound of my
voice. I'm sorry guys. Uh,
it was, uh, it was all
done very quickly. Uh,
between the time of, yes, let's do a
sequel to, let's shoot the sequence.
Who'd would coming out?
It's probably been nine months total.
And so the guys had a short period
of time to write the script in. Um,
I would say all in all a pretty good
amount of influence, as much as,
as they were willing to
listen to me talk and talking,
talking to rewrites and notes with them.
But they're so great and so inclusive
and I think they wanted it to be as good,
if not better as the first one.
And so they were more than willing to
sit down and talk to anybody who is
willing to,
to give them notes.
We were so excited when we heard the,
at least I was when I heard the idea of
like where the SQL would be sad or what
time of the year because there really
isn't another period where, you know,
Mama's in particular are so expected to
make magic happen for everybody else in
their, in their lives. And it's like,
you know, the current, you know,
behind the curtain,
she's sweating and miserable.
And then there's like an innate comedy
timeline of Christmas Eve. You know,
it's like inherently you have to try to
get to, there's a countdown. So like,
you know, comedy wise, we
knew and it, you know, it's,
it's such a crazy,
crazy pressure in for no reason where
it should just be, um, you know,
this magic time with everybody.
And of course it should be fun and
it should be fun. And it gets so,
and it's earlier and earlier,
clearly, I mean, it's October,
but it's so clearly earlier and
earlier in my Christmas list already,
and I've started shopping.
I know I start now.
Yeah,
I really do.
But then by thanksgiving I don't
have any Christmas shopping.
I'm done. Yeah. Well, your mother's
are played by award winning.
Susan Surandon,
Kristin brand ski and Cheryl Hines.
Did any of you have a role in
casting your onscreen moms? Yes. Yes.
Yeah. So you were just like, let
me think of who I want. And yes,
they were like, but that's, and
then they were like, yeah, sure.
Write them a letter and you're like,
okay.
And people respond. It's
kind of crazy. So smooth.
The directors are very confident,
but also like, they're resigned.
They're not like gigantic personalities,
the jump into a room,
but they're confident enough to know that
they take all advice and all ideas and
they use the ones they like and there's,
there's just something sort
of beautiful about that.
So they listened to all
of our Christmas stories,
thought about like what we would want our
characters doing and then they thought
about how they would
place that into the film.
And I think the same thing went
with the moms. They were like,
who do you connect to? You? Who would you
feel like you would want to work with?
Who are you friendly with?
Who Do you think is wonderful for this?
But there they're really,
really collaborative. Yeah.
It seems like it was a
perfect cast. So, uh,
one of my favorite lines is delivered
by Christine Baranski. She says,
you're a mom. Moms don't enjoy,
they give joy. That's how mom had,
that's how being a mom works.
And can you tell us more about each of
their characters and what we can expect?
Uh, there all, no, you go ahead.
Um, my mom is played by Cheryl
Hines, who weirdly enough has been a,
like a friend of mine for about a decade.
So I was like,
this is where would you
want to play my mom?
And we can just add a weird line that
you had me when you were like 10 or
something. And she was like, sure.
Um, so, but so we already had like a,
a very strong friendship on
going into it and we, uh,
we share a similar sense of humor and
I sort of idolized her and I was so
excited that she said yes and they,
the storyline with Kiki,
we pretty much wrote itself and that
of course Kiki has the issue she has
because she had an overbearing mother,
like an intensely overbearing mother,
a mother that were her face
on her sweatshirt often
and a mother that like cuts
and colors her hair exactly the same.
A mother that just like cannot stop
living through her daughter and how much
pressure Kiki feels and how that
makes her sort of neurotic and,
uh, unable to set a boundary because
she's fearful of hurting her mom.
Which, um, you know,
I've experienced and, uh,
it was wonderful to be
able to work in a safe,
fun environment with Cheryl
who's like one of the best,
also improv female comedians
we have out there. So she,
I feel like brought a ton to it.
And I was just really
grateful that she said yes.
Um, I had the pleasure of Christine
Baranski who came about of me going, hmm,
who makes me nervous. And I was
like, Christine Baranski, uh, my,
my character in the first one was
constantly trying to be perfect.
Um, and that was her whole spiral
of like, how do I, you know, uh,
beat the ideals of perfection.
So the mother that I get in the movie,
it's somebody who is,
uh,
who has to have everything be exactly
the way the public would want it to
perceive.
So everything has to visually be great.
Does it matter what's
happening behind closed doors?
But you don't air your dirty laundry
and everything has to be perfect and the
kids have to be happy and
it has to be the best.
This and everything has to be perfect and
wonderful and great. And so I was like,
who makes me nervous as a person?
And I literally went,
Christine Baranski kind of makes me
nervous. And um, and I was like, well,
let's see what happens. And like
literally that's how it went about.
And then I emailed her and was like,
hey, there's this little movie.
We did call it bad mom's like, I went
on a whole thing and she was like, yeah,
okay. And that was it. And I was
like, do you want to read the script?
Like did you, she's like, no, no,
that's fine. And then the directors,
John has got met with her and pitched
her the idea of this character that's a
very overbearing mother and you know,
all the moms ultimately have a,
a reason as to why they
are the way that they are,
which explains why our characters
became the way they became,
which is very reminiscent of if you,
you are who your parents are in your,
you know,
whether your parents were,
we're constantly driving you
and you fought against it
and you became a rebel or
you went into it and became,
you know,
Mark Zuckerberg or like whatever
version of that you became. It is true.
You are what your parents are.
And so in this case,
I think this gives an explanation as
to why we as mothers are so constantly
fighting for perfection.
And it also like,
I think what they did a great job of in
this movie is they give the moms enough
behind the curtain time and peel
away the onion time where you,
it does sort of resonate that like guys,
everybody's doing the best they can
with what they've got, you know?
And that like, it rings true
for our characters, but it also,
throughout the course of the movie you
see like, yeah, your mom is so annoying,
but she's doing the best she can
with what she got and explains why.
Like you no longer resent your parents.
Yeah. And let me take that back.
I met Larry Page,
not mark Zuckerberg.
Hey guys, I apologize. I
also mean Eric Schmidt.
Uh, we can go down the list.
I didn't meet that. Sorry.
No,
I gotta get on this Bob Game Too. You
guys. You got your hair looks so awesome.
Both of yours. I feel like I'm the
odd, odd woman out with this long.
Her fuck the hair guys. Yeah. Um,
Susan Surandon you guys,
it's not so, I mean,
I was so excited and similarly I was like,
who?
There's only one person in the world
that would make Carla feel small and that
would be her mother.
And then I was so excited that at the
thought of it being Susan and I wrote her
as well, I did Spanish. I was like,
oh my God, I gotta I just knew it.
And then even just being in a
scene with her would be very,
it would take me a second
because I would just,
it would be all those movies would,
it was like film Lewis deadman
walking rocky horror picture show.
So it's like hard to like refocus into,
cause she's such a goddess. They all are.
We really lucked out with these women.
And so yeah, I think in their dynamic,
Carla and her mom,
it's more,
I think they were more like kind
of siblings and mother daughter.
You know what I mean? There was not a lot
of boundaries. Friendship. Yeah, exactly.
Well we were thinking about
how you celebrate the holidays
since it is a holiday film.
Can you share what some of your favorite
traditions are and if you are sharing
this with your children?
Oh my God. Well when I
grew up, we used to have to sing happy
birthday baby Jesus on Christmas Eve.
I'm not kidding you. My mom would get a
case and we would be like happy birthday.
And I had so many questions.
I was like, how many candles?
Like it was so confusing.
I have not,
I've not pass that on,
but that was something we had to do.
I don't really sing.
Happy Birthday Baby Jesus.
Be Birthday
Baby Jesus. And we're all
like, just did it. So weird.
Baskin Robbins Santa Claus cake.
So it was confusing at all.
A lot of levels. Even better. Yeah.
I got nothing you got,
I know that we can top that
tradition that I've passed down.
I don't really happen and done. I mean
no, cause you know, I'm Jewish you guys,
so not to be like mom didn't
really celebrate Christmas,
but I'm sorry.
I also grew up in communist Russia
where you don't really sell it,
but I do now. So yay. Um,
I think like we're creating traditions
is the best way that I can explain it.
So you know, uh, our kid doesn't,
I explain this, she's having a
hard time grasping why a man,
it's coming into our house through
a chimney. So spoiler alert,
we're not teaching her about Santa Claus,
not teaching her,
but we try to explain to her that there's
a man that's coming into the house and
she was like,
Ooh,
is okay. But if you're a kid
believes in it, it's great.
Oh he's got a bunch of
exotic cars on the roof.
He's in a jumpsuit and combat boots.
But like don't worry kids in a
Hyatt because mine is not buying it.
Should it does one of them
doesn't Harley or Jay Hernandez?
Maybe that would be okay.
That's where my daughter Mary though,
because do I get it?
Try to be so honest about everything else.
And even like during Easter I was like
bunny too far. It's too far. I was like,
we play a game where we
pretend and imagine this giant
bunny brings us an Easter
basket, but mommy went to the store and
got this for you. But around Christmas,
everyone talks about it and you don't
ever want to say it in front of another
kid because you don't want to insult
another parent and like take over.
That's their domain, but like I'm
having a hard timeline to them.
If I tried lying, I'm
really trying. I'm like,
see it as totally isin tooth fairy.
You name it,
but also so like, but then when
they find out they're going to go,
what else have you lied to me about it?
That's what's confusing. It's like, shit,
I shouldn't have your right.
It lost it.
It's when your kids have questions
about God, but then you're like,
but with definitively like,
but there's a tooth fairy.
People believe this here.
It's confusing.
I was babysitting yesterday
and extra kid in my house here.
Some of the questions that I fielded
throughout the day is Santa Claus real and
I couldn't say anything in front
of the other kid who may dogs.
Why is the earth
literally, I was like,
no, that was the question,
and they're just like painting and
they're like dogs and I was like,
oh my God,
where's my husband?
Sounds like an awesome play date. I'm
on Kiki in real life. It's so sad.
It's a planet. Well,
you're all working moms.
And the pressures of being a perfect
parent is something that we all relate to.
So is there a secret to your
work life integration? Uh,
and then what do you do
to recharge?
I love my,
my girlfriends,
like my tribe of other mamas and humans
than that I love and that we share the
same kind of philosophy. You know,
you just find your group and um,
I cherish that. And then I think
the balance, it's really hard.
It's hard. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I try not to say balance anymore because
I can't balance exists. No, it doesn't.
It doesn't, it's just, it just, it is
really like it. I've always thought like,
it really does suck that biologically.
Like our chief moneymaking years are
lined up with our, like fertility.
Like it just blows, you know what
I mean? It's just what it is.
But it really sucks for us.
I'm going to have some more of a mess
that let's drink some more and just make
the most out.
Any secrets to just recharging,
signing off. I mean self care is huge.
I think like just knowing when you're
feeling frustrated and knowing when you
need to call a girlfriend or when you
need to even like just tag team with your,
like we in our household will be like,
I'd be like, I got to switch kids.
I don't want this one anymore but doing
this one right now because like one of
them will be particular. I'm not,
I don't want, I want to switch.
And then he's like, got
it. Totally, totally.
And then we switch because
sometimes you just need,
you just need to know when
you're getting higher,
your thermometer is getting higher and
whether that goes for like, oh it's been,
you know, four months since I've had like
a girl's dinner, I'm going to do that.
Any amount of self care
and never, ever, ever,
ever beating yourself up
for needing self care.
I used to do that all the
time and I was like, no,
I should be of service and my
family. And I was like, no,
I can get a manicure like once
every six months. Like, that's okay.
Do you know what I mean?
And not killing myself for it.
And also surrendering to the
fact that there is no balance.
It is only had just have a mantra
like just be where you are.
Like when I'm at home, I focus
on my family. When I'm at work,
I focused on work and scroll through
pictures of my family. But you,
you just have to be where you are. It's
really just mindfulness. Like there's no,
the balance is such a
sad joke, you know? Yeah.
I mean I can just talk for
the sake of talking, but I
actually have to this, yeah,
everything that you said. I agree with
those. There's no, there's no balance it,
but I also don't want it to be like a
woman thing. There's just no balance.
If you're a working parent,
there is a balance.
It doesn't matter if
you're a man or a woman.
I am incredibly fortunate and I've
said this before and I'll say it again.
I do have an amazing partner
in life. I do who? Just, yeah.
Ooh, that's right. Who? My partner,
he's fucking awesome and I'm
not going to shit on him because
he's great.
And guess who was home with the kids
today at five in the morning when I was
getting ready, he was, he
was awesome and I, you know,
I had to go away for five months to to
shoot something and he took the time off
from work. He was like, um,
you know, we travel as a tribe
as I know you do where one goes,
the other one follows with the kids
and for five months he was on a flip
schedule. So I, you know,
we were in Europe so he would work from
9:00 PM to like five in the morning and
then be with the kids all day.
Never once did he complain and all
the time he would go, you know what,
I'm so blessed that I get to spend
this much time with the kids.
And it's the most great, like it's you
take it for granted. Having a partner,
whether it's you know, hired help
or a husband or a wife or whatever,
anyone that allows you to just be like,
I can't do this anymore. To your point,
don't take them for granted.
Don't.
Because I think it's the one thing that
I sometimes forget to do is just simply
say thank you. Because as much as
I'm like, I'm about to explode,
I need to go and lock myself up in the
closet for a minute. He's like, Babe,
you got this. Go. And I'm like,
okay.
But like you just,
I think that we should just be grateful
for whatever help it is that you're able
to can see whether it's your friends,
your girlfriends, your village, your mom,
your dad. I feel guilty for relying
on hell, never feel guilty about it.
And that's the one thing that I think
both of you helped me with two years ago
because I had the hardest time
asking for help two years ago when I,
when I did bad moms,
the first one was the first time
I'm back to work after having kids.
And I literally was like, you
know, as Daniel Tiger says,
like when you're feeling frustrated,
step back and ask for help,
y'all fucking step back and ask for help.
It's okay.
And it took me for ever to be okay with
it and you and you were the biggest
champions of that.
So I think you,
it's true. Well cheers to our
girlfriends and our partners.
We'll go ahead and start taking
questions if you want to line up and uh,
I guess to wrap up. Yeah. Where would each
of you like to see your characters go?
If there was a third film to Hawaii
on vacation destination.
Actually vacation takes a lot of work.
No, the bad moms. I feel you
planning a family vacation.
Yeah. Having everything
you need a plane ride. Yup.
And I forgot seeing is like a lock up our
kids in their car seats once. Oh yeah.
Car seat. Strap them on that airplane
in the car that you have to run. Yeah,
we could go on and on. Great. So we'll go
ahead and start with the first question.
Hi, thanks so much for coming to Google.
It's great to see all of you. Um,
my question is how was working on this
set of bad moms different than other sets
you worked done in the past?
Well it does a Christmas movie and we
shot it in Atlanta in May and June.
So that was relaxing
of sweat in places I didn't know could,
could gather.
I think we were also kind of like,
whereas the last movie we had a lot of
peers and like we were all very friendly.
This movie,
we were all sort of like in awe of like
the things that Christine and Susan and
Sheryl warp sort of bringing and we fell.
I feel like I felt a little bit more
like a fan girl on this. Not that I'm
not in love with the other
women that we worked with,
but this just felt a little bit more like,
I don't know,
like why are they doing our movie?
This is so exciting.
Thank you so much.
Hi,
I'll second that. Thank you so
much for coming to Google tag. Um,
one of my favorite parts of the
first movie, which was amazing,
but the very end where each of you
were interviewed with your moms.
I thought it was incredibly touching
and so I'm transparent of view is
especially in the public light
to have your moms be there. Um,
so with your new stage
moms in the second one,
did your moms get to meet
any of your screen moms? No,
my mom did.
She got,
she happened to be there while we were
doing like a gallery shoot or so remember
we were doing the publicity and so
she got to meet her and shoot that,
which was very, very exciting. Yeah.
But those first interviews
were so dear and remember like,
do you remember they ended up
being like incredible interviewers.
John and Scott are directors and writers
actually did the interviews for all of
us as a couple, you know, the,
the mothers and daughters and it was there
pretty revealing. It got real deep in.
They're very,
Barbara Walters was really well done.
Yeah,
no,
my mom has not met Christine brandscaping
but their historic mom's five feet on
a good day. Like if she stands up royally
tall, she's maybe five feet though.
And like she's tiny. She's just
a tiny little thing and you know,
because nobody's the tall and beautiful.
My Mom's like,
that's what I imagined myself as
and it's very cute. So they
will meet, I mean, yeah, for
sure. They're both awesome.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I think we have one last question.
Great.
Hi.
Um, so thank you. First
off for doing the movie,
giving us a reason to go get drunk and
get all the like weird kind of awkward
moms from preschool together
represent body moms. Thank you.
Get some girl and erotic. Really
organized. Um, I loved it.
I was just curious which pieces really
resonated the most with you? Like,
if you could have chosen the characters,
like would you have chosen the
character that you got to sign? Yeah.
Yes, yes. Without, AH, yeah. Yes. I
cannot, I can go on a very lengthy,
lengthy explanation as to why.
But uh, with the first bad moms,
that was me. I literally was like, I had
so much pressure that I put on myself,
not anybody else of like, everything has
to be perfect for my kid, for my life,
everything organize
and to figure this out.
And I literally was going crazy
cause I was like, what's a shower?
Like I forgot to take care of myself
so much so that I need, like I,
it was the most perfect um,
therapy session was doing this movie.
They like both of these films have
been like giant therapies for me.
I'd say Carlos is more
as my s my spirit animal.
Like I wish that's actually
reassuring. Yeah. Yeah. I wish,
I think we all wish we got a little inner
inner, oh yeah. We all have some of her.
When I first read that Mila had this
script and she called me and she was like,
read this script. You Ha you
should do this with me. And
I read it and I was like, this
is so good. And I was like,
maybe I should play the bitchy one. Like
I wanted to play Chris, remember this,
I want to play Christina's role.
I was like,
she's so funny and that would be so
cool cause like I can be super bitchy.
And she was like, no, no, no, you're
Kiki Kiki. That's it. And I was like,
okay, cool. And then I realized
like that's such a Kiki thing to do,
to be like, Ooh man, I completed
a vixen and everyone be like, no,
that's not your essence.
Okay,
thanks for being true to yourself.
Well in closing on behalf of
all the bad moms like Google,
I want to thank you for portraying the
realities of being a mom and giving us a
reason to have a mom's night out.
So be sure to watch a bad moms Christmas
out in theaters on November 1st I want
a micro kitchen 400 feet from where I am.
That's the best idea.
[inaudible].